bachar el-assad doit trouver une
résolution politique du conflit syrien
s'il ne veut pas voir son pays acculé
par de nouvelles sanctions économiques
américaines avec la loi à césar
washington met la pression maximale sur
damas pour l'obliger à déposer les armes
la maison blanche prévoit notamment le
gel de l'aide à la reconstruction et des
sanctions contre le gouvernement syrien
les personnes ou les entreprises qui
collaborent avec damas sont également
ciblées quatre secteurs sont visés les
hydrocarbures l'aéronautique militaire
les finances puis le bâtiment et travaux
publics la loi césar intervient alors
que les syriens sont déjà à étrangler
économiquement nous avons traversé de
nombreuses difficultés si dieu le veut
nous survivrons à cela comme nous avons
survécu à ce qui a eu lieu auparavant
nous sommes habitués depuis 2011 nous
vivons dans une situation de crise
depuis dix ans nous comptons sur nos
propres forces
nous mangeons ce que nous cultivons dans
nos jardins pour le ministre syrien de
l'économie
avec cette loi césar washington veut en
fait prolonger la guerre contre la syrie
mais aussi coupé l'élan stratégique d
allié de bachar al assad
parmi ces pays aux côtés de damas la
russie ni la russie qui tout au long de
son histoire millénaire enduré beaucoup
d'épreuves plus grande que celle ci ni
la syrie qui a survécu à de nombreuses
années de guerre brutale contre le
véritable terrorisme ne peuvent être
réprimées par la terreur économie un
nouveau train de sanctions économiques
condamné ce mardi par le chef du
mouvement libanais du hezbollah
militairement engagés auprès des forces
de bachar al assad dans une allocution
retransmise à la télévision
hassan nasrallah a estimé que la loi
césar était la dernière arme des
etats-unis contre le pouvoir syrien
c'est la dernière arme américaine pour
assiéger la syrie et faire pression
on lui interdisant d'acheter de vendre
d'avoir affaire à la banque centrale aux
banques syriennes et aux institutions de
l'état et pour affamer le peuple syrien
en portant atteinte à sa livre
washington peut décider de suspendre ces
nouvelles sanctions à n'importe quel
moment la condition imposée par les
états unis cesser les bombardements
aient accepté de juger les responsables
de crimes de guerre syriens la loi césar
inspiré par un ancien photographe
militaire syrien a été promulguée fin
décembre par le président donald trump
l'union européenne pour sa part a
renouvelé le 28 mai dernier les mesures
de pression prises à l'encontre de la
syrie en 2011 une liste noire établie
par bruxelles à l'encontre de personnes
mais aussi de banques entreprises organe
étatique encore des secteurs entiers
comme le pétrole
placé sous embarque aux îles mariannes à
karaj porte parole du ministère russe
des affaires étrangères
elle pointe du doigt la responsabilité
de l'union européenne est décevant que
fin mai après les états unis l'union
européenne et pris la décision de
prolonger les sanctions unilatérales
contre la syrie on a indiqué plusieurs
fois que des restrictions pareil mutile
non seulement l'économie syrienne
mais empêche aussi l'achat de
médicaments vitaux d'équipements
médicaux et de biens humanitaires